字幕: Huizi Tian
校正: Yoshiaki Yamagami
（拍手）
ついていませんが　大丈夫か
はい 今 ご紹介いただきました
井出と言います
慶応大学の教員をやっています
多分 今日ね
いらっしゃっている皆さんは
慶応に進む方が たくさんいらっしゃると
思いますけれども
僕の場合は自分語りをしちゃうと
多分５秒ぐらいで追い出されちゃう
10分という限られた時間の中で
大学って一体
どういうことを勉強するのかなというのを
皆さんにお話ししようと思っています
今日ね 税金の話をきっかけに 入り口にして
皆さんと少し
一緒に考えてみようかなと思っているんですね
この中で 税金が好きだ
喜んで払いたいという人って
どれくらいいますか？
手挙げてください
よく見えないけど
いないよね きっとね
そうなんです
税金を喜んで払うバカってたぶんいないです
なぜかというと
自分の財布ね 一生懸命頑張って
お金をせっかく稼いだのに
そこに国が手を突っ込んで
君たちの大事なお金を取っていくわけですね
こんなことを
喜んで受け入れる人って普通いないですよ
でも この当たり前の事実から
大学で勉強するということの
問いをちょっと考えてみましょう
じゃあ 政府がもし君たちから
税金を取らなかったら
いったいどうなるんでしょうか？
君たちは今 夢と希望で
いっぱいだと思うんだよね
もう僕なんか
50過ぎちゃってポンコツですよ
もう肩の筋肉なんて
この間切れちゃって
左肩がもう上がらないんです
（笑）
いや 笑うところじゃないです
でもそんな僕に比べて
君たちはもう夢と希望でいっぱいなんですね
年収 将来どんぐらいいく？
１千５百 行きますか？
２千万くらいいきますか？
もっといく もっといく
と思っているヤツいるでしょう
でも気をつけてね
君たちが例えば年収１千５百万を稼いで
パートナーも１千５百万で３千万
すごいよね
だけど どっちか片方が病気をして倒れる
心の病を持つ 職場にいけない クビになる
その瞬間に年収って
半分になっちゃうじゃないですか？
しかも君たちは
年収１千５百万 ３千万
慶応に来て 勉強して
いい大学行って いい会社入ってね
自分の力で生きてきた
金稼いでんだって思うじゃないですか
でもちょっと考えてほしいんだよね
君たち水道で水を飲むよね
あれ誰が作ったの？
税金ですよね？
道路 誰が作ってる？
電気 誰が通してくれてる？
病院 君たち行ったら３割負担
まあ今タダの人もいるか？ まだ
じゃあなんでタダなの？
なんで３割で済むの？
学校 誰が作ってるの？
自衛隊 誰が作ってるの？
図書館 誰が作ってるの？
これ全部税金ですよね
君たちが大金持ちになって
将来 レクサスでも 何でもいいですけど
高級車に乗る
どんなに威張ったって
君たちが使っている道路は税金でできている
ということは 税金払うの もし嫌だとしたら
君たちは
自分で軍隊を作り 自分で道路を作り
自分で図書館を作ったり
水道を作ったりって
とてもじゃないけど 無理ですよね
僕たちの税金というのが
そういう使われ方をしている
さあ じゃ ここでひとつ仮説を
設けてみたいと思います
税金がとても大事だってことは
なんとなくわかったと思う
だけど みんな「いや 払いたくない」
じゃあなぜ？　仮説を立ててみます
例えば 政府の人 政治家
多分 君たち あんまり好きじゃないよね？
あまり信じてないよね？ 多分
そいつらが何か悪いことして
ずるいことして
無駄遣いして 金使っているのに
なんで俺が税金払わなきゃいけないの？
って思うかもしれない
あるいは 自分が真面目に払っているのに
脱税してるやつがたくさんいるじゃないか？
なんで俺払わなきゃいけないんだ
と思う人がいるかもしれない
借金まみれ
今 国が借金まみれってのは皆知ってますか？
誰がした？君たちじゃない
俺たちだよね
ごめんね 威張っちゃって
俺たちだよ
なのに
なんで君たちが税金を払わなきゃいけないの？
あるいは人のために金払うくらいなら
どうせ あいつら ろくな使い方をしないから
俺が稼いだ金を 私が稼いだ金を
自分で自分のために使いたい とかね
なんとなくこんな理由があって
きっと税金を嫌うんでしょうね
でもさ これをよく見てごらん
人間って信じられないな
人間って嘘つきじゃん
ということを言っているわけですよね
じゃあもしそうだという
仮説がもしそうだとするならば
ちょっと見てみよう
北欧って君たちわかりますか？
知ってる？
スウェーデンとか
フィンランドとか ノルウェーとかね
すっごい税金が高いことで
有名な国々があります
中間層 つまり普通の年収の人たちの税負担を
どう思いますか？って聞くんですね
例えば 一番上
これね あまりにも高い
高すぎるって答えた人を
この中まで見てほしいんだけど
一番上にデンマークがあって
ちょっと下にフィンランドがあって
ノルウェーあって
スウェーデンあって ここね
そしてずっと下の方に日本があるんです
何を言いたいか
日本というのは先進国の中で
税金が安いことで有名な国なんです
まずそこからして
ちょっとびっくりかもしれないね
日本って税金が安い
北欧の国々の方が
はるかに税金は高い 重たい
なのに
税金が高すぎる 税金は苦痛だって
答える人の割合は北欧の方が少ないです
そうだよね
だって人間を もし信じられないとしたら
信じられない奴のために払っている税金
税金ってそうじゃない？
自分のためじゃなくて
みんなのために使うよね
その信じられない人間のために
取られる税金が痛いのが当たり前だよね
反対に
これから次のデータをまたお見せしますが
今度は
人間を信頼できますか？という質問に対して
これちょっとね 悲しくなるからね
ごめんね 俺の性格が悪いんじゃないよ
こういうデータだからね
日本人は「君たちどう？
人間を信じられますか？」って聞いた時に
「信じられます」と答える人の割合が
日本って めっちゃ少ないんです
めっちゃ少ないです
そして さっき言ったデンマーク 一番上
上から２番目ノルウェー
４番目 スウェーデン
ちょっと落ちて
フィンランドはここにありますけれども
北欧の人たちは人間信じているわけです
要するに 信じられる仲間のためなら
税金を払っても構わないかもしれないけれども
信じられない人間のために
税金を払うのが嫌だ
だから日本は人間を実際に信じていない
税の痛みも強い
そして 租税負担率といって
税金を取られる割合も低い
だってみんな払うの嫌だから
ていうことが見えてくるわけですね
そうするとね
人間を信じられない社会というのは
どういう社会になるか
ちょっとね 悲しすぎるデータを
君たちに二つ紹介しようと思います
一つは 今から話すのは
政府の責任だと思いますかという質問です
いいですか これに反対した人の割合
ノーと答えた人の割合を見ます
病人が病院に行けるようにする
反対と答えた人の割合は
こんなの政府の仕事じゃないって
答えた人の割合は
35の国の中で日本１位です
高齢者の生活を支援すること
反対 １位
失業者の暮らしを守ってあげる
反対 ２位
所得の格差を小っちゃくする
反対 ６位
貧しい世界の大学生を助けよう
反対 １位
家を持てない人にそれなりの家を与えよう
どう君たち？
弱い立場に置かれている人たちじゃないですか
病人 高齢者 失業者 貧しい人
貧しい家庭の大学生 家を持っていない人
その人たちに対して
助けてあげようという意志を
少なくとも他国と比べたときに
最も持っていない国が日本だと思います
君たちが生きていく社会というのは
そういう社会だと思います
それはそうだよね 人間信じてないから
あるいは 格差を小さくする ―
お金持ちがいてね
すいません
お金持ちがいて 貧しい人がいて
この格差を小さくしたかったら
金持ちに税金をどんどんかけていけば
格差は小さくなるじゃん
貧しい人にお金をあげていけば
どんどん格差が小さくなるじゃん
貧しい人に お金をあげて
格差を小さくする力は
調査した国の中でビリから３番目
金持ちに税金をかけて
格差を小さくする財政の力は
調査した国の中でビリなんですよね
こういう社会が出来上がっている
ってことに気づくわけです
さあ最後 あと30秒か
誰もが嫌いな税金というところを
今日は入り口にしました
そして いろんなデータを見てみました
仮説を設けてみて
いろんなデータを探ってみました
そうすると何がわかったかというと
当たり前の事実
税金なんて払うのがいやだという
当たり前の事実から入っていきながら
この社会の悲しい現実が見える
そして変えたい
変えなければいけないという
そういう現実に
君たちはたどり着くことができる
なんで僕たちは人間を信じられないんだろう？
どうすればこの社会で
人間を信じられるようになるんだ？
そういう巨大な巨大な問いに
君たちが出会っていくわけです
高校の間は効率的に勉強して
効率的にいい点数を取ることを競い合う
しかし 大学は違います
当たり前の事実に気づき 疑問を持ち
そして巨大な問いにぶつかり挑んでいく
これが大学の学問です
どうですか 楽しくないですか？
君たちの税金は嫌いだというその感情が
この社会の姿に結びついている
ということは
この社会を君たちが変えていけば
君たち自身が幸せになれる
ということかもしれない
この大きな目標に向かって学ぶ
それが大学という素晴らしい場所です
ぜひ皆さんいらしてください
たくさん勉強してください
どうもありがとうございます
（拍手）